now this first one here right in
ascending order we know it's about sighs
which way is it smaller because
obviously smaller it's more than Vegas
because they're sending means going up
inside for their increasing okay you
should have the smallest number a
surprise and the biggest number at the
end okay now hey don't rate who agree
yes sean is wonderful thank you Miss
down are these are just included it
right you can see what I trying to do to
make this a little bit a little bit more
listen to the way you know where it is
if I provided the ability to perform yes
what's it called it's a decimal because
then it laughs okay but they're all
different ways of talking about the same
kinds of object now we can know quickly
the 0.09 9 has to be the smallest wife
Darren yeah yeah that guy that guy said
you know what can hit all these guys
these tiny bikes 10 times smaller than
all the rest of us okay that's the first
thing I know when you compare these two
okay hands up how did we know the Nile
ends with smaller the ninety percent
then you take it anytime you someone
else's yeah right which is a highly
allergic what did you convert into what
which work I'm going to be doing try to
work out which one it is Danielle what
did you do 90 is contestant on a little
of it ok it happen yeah very good so
what the treaty things last question is
because they're all talking in different
languages at some point you're going to
have to do some conversions but some
conversion 3z other ones okay much so
9411 reason you could convert that into
a percentage it's nothing stopping you
but it's a very inefficient way to go
about it like it's much simpler just to
say well I can turn these into a
fraction 9 10 w 9 11 right like you're
taking the same starts at the numerator
and you're dividing into more chunks or
less chocolate what happened last one
how did you know that was the biggest
yeah
my difference between I you have very
good so you can get again you another
conversion right you can see actually
the comparison is quite easy semester
sometimes okay let's have a look at the
equation in the middle the outer joins
in his room and jennifer i think is x
equals lady of 94 13 showing it will
refer ok it's officially illustrate okay
keep your head down I see a few his but
not that many so I like to work out
whether this is right or not and whether
they can convince ourselves one way or
the other that this step is really
important we need to look at it is very
helpfully giving us some lines of work
with the look at each line and try to
work out what's going on okay why 14
line to from the question jess is first
light of working what she done hands up
someone lon jennifer to explain what
she's done ya khushi 5s three X plus 1
and yes okay so I regular from not too
bad this idea of cross multiplying is a
very efficient way to go about this
confusion such a pants down there for a
second and I want you to be cautious
with this here's one I'm actually
teaching something very similar this in
my year 11 class at the moment and it's
really easy to confuse cross multiplying
with something very similar but
different let me show you learning if I
ask you to solve that that's another
equation got more X's and more fractions
algebraic fractions absorbacron Andrew
now it's very tempting so what is this
question and they all look a pair of
these fractions I know what to do i am
going to cross multiply so you this is
it and I 340g student you're 11 and 12
licenses they're working they cross
multiply we can assume that and maintain
us at five plus plus eight x + 4 x
equals really i'm dividing our side 58
right so i'm pretty sure that the corner
okay 2/8 whatever force be with me an
old wall but an angry cooperating right
okay now it all looks so nice and
convincing it sounded great except for
one glaring problem life okay so this is
nominator beyond right this is so
important is why i'm making a big deal
of people often are will cross multiply
but not really know why it works i'm
going to suggest something different I
have to do so you look to say cross
multiply even though it's exactly what
it looks like in it just it so nicely
give you years I d better dear from what
you're really doing and on your line of
work to whatever you have done I'd like
you to add this instead on the original
line what we've done for Jennifer Dodd
is she has multiplied this by 10 and
since in an equation if you do something
to one side then you better do it
together you're great so they will this
guy also get x 10 now I wonder if you
can see the problem before with how i
did this you put in a quarter you will
not get the solution okay f on three
turns into 5x what if i multiplied it by
to do that exon 3 turn into 5mm i think
i've multiplied like this thing you see
that 15 x over 3 is 5 m15x emissary you
can still know if you find a strange i
was it what we multiply this by to get
to that again it's 15 because um 15x7
525 camera with 3x wherever it follows
that is if you multiply these by 16 then
shouldn't you multiply it something else
like 15 as well so this guy over here
what should become 30 apply x equals of
quarters not the answer so rather than
staying cross multiplying I'm going to
encourage you to think about what is it
you do to both sides okay what are these
a good plan no one's going hold on this
year okay oh he's getting that hip ok so
after that after that are you convinced
by the working she had x 110 what did
you do on to that can you describe to me
was what she's done community yeah
what yes you know give me a hug someone
help about ok Emily really hold on
careful now get let me know about you ok
so what's yahi I'm hearing all the
language and if you guys are doing the
questions I heard this as well just like
I Pete talked about this is hot
multiplying is dangerous kind of work
you know you're doing right I'm saying I
took the initiative to where I took it
to the other side and then when i took
it over it became negative what doesn't
really did it she'd subtracted 2x from
both sides you see that the same
operation not at the same time that's
what 15 x becomes there's a letter bomb
ok and then that's the right end up
roughly 18 square centimeters thumbs up
thumbs up yes
[Music]